[Musique]
six ans après baptiste duluc nous
retrouvons sur les lieux c'est bien ça
pas grand chose a changé
vous connaissez bien je reconnais très
bien oui rien hassan diab ce n'est rien
mais vous par contre vous avez beaucoup
changé que s'est il passé une grande
aventure je crois que en août octobre il
est puissant ou pas et c'est oui mais le
soir de fête dans cette affaire-là
quand personne a voulu me suis endormi
j'étais chez moi et puis quand même me
suis réveillé j'étais perdu j'étais sur
une planète quelle planète et commande
pour nom se retrouver sur une planète
c'était l'après ceux qui mendient
c'était là j'en ai trouvé sur la galaxie
14 et comment ça s'est passé ce voyage
s'est rendu compte de rien d'absolument
ne rien de toute façon là où j'ai
toujours été bien reçus et ai été invité
à commenter cette planète
ces grandes quoi ça peut être la
végétation comme ici là c'est vrai c'est
pas pareil du tout c'est les petits
géants au programme comme ça là c'est
pas pareil du tout et les habitants de
la planète commenté t-il c'était les
mêmes que ceux de la soucoupe volante
cela recoupe était quand même un peu
plus grande oui les autres étaient plus
petits une petite terrasse bichonne tous
très gentils
nous avons autant vous le dire beaucoup
de mal à vous croire c'est pour ça que
nous vous posons beaucoup de questions
mais c'est baptiste de lui mais comment
se déroulait par exemple une journée sur
la galaxie 14 ans j'écoutais de la
musique a des fois
et quel genre de musique juillet
comment c'est fait alors ce retour sur
la terre là hier mais son retour
paraît-il qui
c'est eux qui me l'ont dit avant de
partir que il me des fans est sur la
terre pour pour que je puisse donner les
renseignements acquis aux scientifiques
du monde est longue
d'ailleurs je crois que vous avez déjà
pris dès votre arrivée plusieurs
contacts et c'est ce qui prouve en fait
que tout ce que vous nous racontez là
est vrai vous avez des contacts avec les
plus éminents experts oui oui qui par
exemple doit partir à bientôt à new york
et puis après je dois aller à cap
kennedy
oui je dois rencontrer le grand
professeur von braun et bien sûr les
communications que vous devez faire à
tous et souvent pour le moment sont
secrètes
ah oui mon nom ne de leur dire au calme
c'est ça ne pas le dire à personne
d'autre mais vous verrez ça va être
confirmée de façon on pouvait avoir
confiance que je vous dire
[Musique]